sur le quai de l'horloge des centaines
de personnes étaient venus voir le
spectacle celui d'une jeune baleine à
bosse qui a élu domicile dans le vieux
port de montréal il y a trois jours à
toutes les deux ou trois minutes la bête
de 10 mètres de longueur refaisait
surface
c'est vraiment pas tous les jours qu'on
a la chance de voir ce même si l'animal
est peinte en détresse en fait on n'a
pas vu une baleine à bosse à montréal
depuis 1901 en temps normal on les
observe
rarement au sud de tadoussac sur la
haute côte nord c'est plus de 400
kilomètres en dehors de son habitat
habituel est pas un trajet
nécessairement facile du monte contre le
courant quelle est la motivation à ce
qu'on a à faire à un animal d orienter
ou un animal gourmand le même faire de
plusieurs dizaines de tomes qui a au
moins trois ans à peut-être poursuivi
des bancs de poissons un peu trop loin
avant de se perdre en chemin
chose certaine pour lui le fleuve à la
hauteur de montréal ne ressemble
certainement pas un gros gars de manger
on sait que ces animaux longs une
capacité de jeunes est assez important
et pourrait aussi passer plusieurs jours
voire quelques semaines ça se nourrir
sans se détériorait trop rapidement
pour l'instant la baleine qu'on appelle
aussi un rorqual à bosse semble toujours
en santé et très énergique mais il ya
maintenant une semaine qu'elle a quitté
sa zone de confort si elle reste là
c'est certain que ça va pas durer très
très bien pour cet animal à parce que si
elle n'arrive pas à trouver de quoi
s'alimenter faiblir sur la côte ouest
dans les années 80 on a réussi à deux
reprises à forcer une baleine à bosse à
quitter la baie de san francisco pour
retourner en haute mer mais ici à 400km
de tadoussac
c'est impensable je suis d'accord sur le
triskell meurt mais je pense pas qu'il y
ait grand chose qu'on puisse faire ce
moment ci heureusement l'histoire de
cette jeune baleine à bosse est encore
loin d'être écrite
oui oui mon ami willy c'est pas une
baleine c'est un art mais on
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal